welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of
Christopher Nolan's Oppenheimer one of
Nolan's best films following scientist J
Robert Oppenheimer Killian Murphy and
his work with a Manhattan Project to
develop the atomic bomb as well as his
fraught political relationship with
Louis straws after World War II in this
video I will analyze Nolan's cinematic
devices the editing structure color
versus black and white the historical
timeline and one fascinating detail that
Nolan included with regards to Florence
Pew's Gene tatlock pointing to some
questions around that person's fate and
if you like this kind of analysis I did
break down Christopher Nolan's
Interstellar and Inception on the Deep
dive Channel and to celebrate Marvin
Heimer weekend I actually reviewed both
movies in a separate video and broke
down the Easter eggs and Barbie please
subscribe to all three channels on the
new rockstars Network and please know
sagafter has informed us that
entertainment journalists like us are
allowed to cover movies like this this
is not a paid promotion and we support
the actors and writers in their strike
and we along with Christopher Nolan were
so proud to see the cast of Oppenheimer
walk out of the movie's premiere alright
let's get started with the breakdown the
film Oppenheimer begins with a shot of
raindrops hitting a puddle forming the
Chain Reaction ripple effect as a young
Oppenheimer stares at them in a school
Courtyard at Cambridge these Ripple
effects are a recurring image throughout
this film representing oppenheimer's
fear of a chain reaction of the release
of atomic energy consuming the world in
fire then images of fire fill the screen
with the text Prometheus stole fire from
the gods and gave it to man for this he
was chained to a rock and tortured for
eternity this is a slight rewarding of a
passage about the Greek mythological
Titan from The Source material of this
film The Pulitzer Prize winning 2005
biography American Prometheus a Triumph
and tragedy of J Robert Oppenheimer
written by KY bird and Martin J Sherwin
this Prometheus myth comes up a lot
whenever we discuss human technological
advancement in the dangers of it but we
often forget prometheus's punishment and
for J Robert Oppenheimer we see that
guilt and psychological torment that he
suffered as a result of his actions
structurally Oppenheimer resembles the
David Fincher film The Social Network a
historical process story framed through
legal proceedings and flashbacks the
first of these in color shows
Oppenheimer in 1954 in a closed hearing
for the renewal of a security clearance
threatened by his past communist
leanings during the era of McCarthyism
Nolan labels this with on-screen text 1.
fission because this mostly flashes back
to oppenheimer's time developing nuclear
fission the division of an atom with the
Manhattan Project in the years before
that and symbolically focuses on his
vision from his colleagues of the
Manhattan Project and the aec and a
vision of his romantic relationships
Oppenheimer was warned about alienated
its colleagues because he might need
them someday and this is where those
chickens come home to roost now the
second of these timelines in Black and
White shows Louis Strauss played by
Robert Downey Jr at his Senate
confirmation Hearing in 1958 when he was
trying to be Commerce Secretary Nolan
labels this with on-screen text to
Fusion referring to the fusion of two
Atomic nuclei which releases vastly
greater energy and fusion is the source
of the hydrogen bombs that were
developed after World War II which
really was the major source of a
contention between Strauss and
Oppenheimer during their time at the aec
in the late 40s and the 50s these two
men men represent dually nuclei being
crammed together when they should not be
to explosive results and by labeling
these fission infusion Nolan signals
that despite the explosive fireworks in
oppenheimer's life up until World War
II's end really the crazier bigger drama
the bigger boom booms came in the fusion
afterwards so when we see Opie's
perspective it's in color when we see
strauss's perspective it's in black and
white this distinction shows strauss's
inability to see the Nuance of these
decisions and his view of the world as a
black and white binary zero-sum game
mutually assured destruction because
it's not just monochrome notice how
Nolan also shoots these scenes with
higher contrast and hotter lighting as
if straws is Happy living in a world
where a thermonuclear blast could ignite
the sky at any moment Nolan hinges both
timelines on one moment 1947 which
Oppenheimer meets dross at Princeton and
Oppenheimer meets with Albert Einstein
beside a pond and says something that
upsets Einstein and Strauss always
assumed that it was an insult about him
an insecurity that eventually undo
straws it's really his tragic flaw but
what Abby actually said is not revealed
into the the final seconds of the film
The Final line even a mystery akin to
what is rosebud and Citizen Kane we
flash back to a real event in which
Oppenheimer tried to poison an apple of
his tutor Patrick blackett apples being
an important symbol to possess as the
orb that struck Newton's head here it
symbolizes Opie's first instinct to
create a weapon of mass destruction
followed by his immediate regret and his
attempt to dispose it this comes after
it's nearly eaten by his admired Idol
Nils Bohr played by Kenneth Branagh
after Opie gives the excuse of quote
Wormhole ah a bit of physicist Wormhole
because not only is it a hole formed by
a worm in the Apple it's also the term
used for theoretical holes in space time
four instructs Hoppe to clear his head
of his Hidden World instead just hear
the music of this world and we follow
OPI as he visits an art gallery he sees
Pablo Picasso's 1937 woman sitting with
arms crossed we see also reads T.S
eliot's the Wasteland a poem known for
Sanskrit mantras which likely would
Inspire oppenheimer's famous quoting of
the Sanskrit passage in the
bhagavad-gita the Wasteland poem
actually begins with spring raindrops as
does this film when Oppenheimer meets
dross stress corrects Abby that it's
pronounced Strasse not Strauss these two
Jewish men referring to the subtle ways
dross has coded himself to sound less
Jewish something Oppenheimer embraced
recognizing that the Nazi's greatest
weakness in this Atomic race was
anti-Semitism as Hitler regarded physics
as quote Jewish science and that drove
away great thinkers like Albert Einstein
Oppenheimer greets Einstein by picking
up his hat after the wind blew it off
wearing brimmed hats is kind of a key
character trait for Opie in this movie
it's what makes the scientist a
scientist as opposed to a military man a
scientist who cares more for the health
of the planet than for winning a war as
Einstein walks away glumly he refuses to
wear his hat because he knows his
research has opened the door for the
planet's Doom is it orabi great zombie
on a train to Zurich as oppy looks out
the window the seat cushion vibrates
behind him for a moment independent of
the Train's normal rattling we see this
throughout the film that represents
Opie's anxiety that hidden within his
world is a world of quantum energy
brimming to explode they watched Werner
Heisenberg lecture her and he starts in
German but as he turns toward Opie and
Robbie he switches to English which is
Christopher Nolan's way of showing how
Abby can understand multiple languages
at Berkeley Opie meets Dr Ernest
Lawrence Josh Hartnett who tells him
Theory can only get you so far an
important stated theme of this movie
that gets repeated over and over again
as the fission half of Opie's career is
dominated by Theory and the fusion half
is dominated by the application that
theory and the impact of it Opie joins
his brother Frank at a communist
Gathering where he meets heikon
Chevalier who will later slightly
pressure Oppenheimer to give him top
secret information that he can pass
along to their Russian allies leading to
the Chevalier incident but here ABI
tells Chevalier about what happens to
stars when they die saying quote the
bigger the star the more violent its
demise and gravity gets so concentrated
that it swallows everything everything
even light so obvious foreshadowing what
will happen to him he becomes a huge
media star and because he becomes so big
he has a steeper demise in which the
emotional gravity swallows everything
even the good things in his life Nolan
describes the same astrophysics and
black holes that he would use in the
movie Stellar both this movie and
Interstellar were advised by Kip Thorne
and remember back in tenet Nolan
mentioned the Oppenheimer story you're
familiar with the Manhattan Project
as they approach the first atomic test
open Hammer became concerned that the
detonation might produce a chain
reaction
so in this weird way Nolan is kind of
linking many of his films together and
this kind of meta textual context Opie
also meets Gene tatlock Florence Pugh
and he brags about reading Karl Marx's
text in the original German translating
it as ownership is theft instead of
properties theft which is an interesting
distinction because it assigns the blame
to the ACT instead of to the object in
the concept of it and Gene uses his
obsession with textual literalism during
sex with Oppenheimer which doesn't go
well but she gets him going by having
him translate the Sanskrit of the
bhagavad-gita the line for now I am
become death the destroyer of worlds
which Oppenheimer throughout his life
would later repeatedly quote to express
his guilt over the Manhattan Project and
it's pretty telling to think that this
could have come from a moment with Gene
tatlock this woman being one of the
worlds he destroyed this video is
sponsored by Helix sleep and yeah I know
it seems like nobody here at new
Rockstar sleeps much but I promise you
we do and thanks to my Helix mattress
I've been getting the best sleep of my
life for years now Helix sleep quiz
makes it so easy you just take the quiz
and Helix finds a perfect match just for
you I wanted a medium firm mattress with
lumbar support that sleeps cool and I
got matched with the dusk Luxe Helix
mattress other mattress companies use
fiberglass in their products Helix
doesn't do that Helix even owns own 100
fiberglass free manufacturing facility
I've had my Helix mattress for two years
now it still feels brand new it's the
best mattress I've ever owned Helix
delivers your mattress right to your
door with free shipping in the US the
mattress comes rolled up in a box and
it's super easy to set up yourself Helix
has a 100 night sleep trial so you get
more than three months to make sure that
you love it Helix mattresses have a 10
year warranty and they even offer
financing options and flexible payment
plans so a great night's sleep is never
far away I love my Helix mattress I
think you would too so if you're looking
for a new bed check out Helix sleep you
can click the link below or go to
helixsleep.com new rockstars to get 20
off your Helix mattress plus two free
pillows Abby meets Colonel Leslie Groves
Matt Damon who appoints Oppenheimer the
director of the Manhattan Project
despite his communist leanings because
he's finally let go of the FAE CT they
pick New Mexico because Oppenheimer says
it's centrally located between Berkeley
Chicago Oak Ridge Tennessee and Hanford
Washington and because he's ranched in
the area he knows it pretty well and
mostly it's just remote helping with
testing and Groves desires for secrecy
income compartmentalization so they
recruit their dream team of scientists
from around the country Opie leads the
research and Edward Teller Benny safety
shares math suggesting the possibility
of a chain reaction that could lead to
atmospheric ignition this freaks him all
the hell out so Oppenheimer takes this
to Albert Einstein and they visualize
the atmosphere Lighting on fire and
notice during the scene and really any
time in this movie that Opie feels this
kind of dread we hear stomping which we
later learn are the Stomps on the wooden
bleachers in the Los Alamos gymnasium
during the Hiroshima Victory party so as
they set up the Los Alamos site they
fill jars with marbles to show the rate
of the enriching uranium and plutonium
to build the bomb device but instead of
bomb Oppenheimer corrects in this scene
quietly Gadget because he wants to avoid
these scientists thinking about how
they're actually building a weapon and
that is how we got the test device's
name the gadget it turns out it's Groves
that brings in Klaus Fuchs to Los Alamos
whom we later learn is the spy who
leaked the bomb info to the Soviets and
during all this Nolan intercuts to 1949
a black and white meeting with the aec
with Strauss angry that the Russians
tested an atomic bomb years before they
were expected to and he pressures
Oppenheimer to brief the president on
teller's research of the hydrogen bomb
and Robert Downey Jr does a great take
on this line saying because if it could
put us ahead again the president of the
United States needs to know about it and
Robert Downey Jr does the slightest
smirk for just a second it's just a
subtle sign of his incredulity that
Oppenheimer would consider himself above
the president it's this smile I think
when Strauss realizes he needs to take
Opie down back in 1943 Opie meets with
Gene tatlock for various intramarital
Affairs despite his new marriage and
family with Kitty and as Oppenheimer
admits his affair in the hearing in 1954
Nolan includes this insane shot where
the camera dollies right past the back
of Robert Rob's head as kitty's eyes
suddenly look up she's been looking down
the entire time throughout this movie
but she looks up right as we pass Rob's
head staring daggers at her husband and
then when we cut back to this moment we
clear Rob's head and now Oppenheimer is
fully nude in this hearing room as Kitty
is visualizing him and Jean having sex
right there in the room establishing
Kitty as an equal point of view
character in this movie Opie learns that
Gene tatlock was found dead and here
comes what I think is the most
intriguing moment of the film because
Nolan includes close-up of a
water-filled tub Gene kneeling on
pillows holding her own head down under
the water taking some pills and leaving
an unsigned note but historically Gene
tatlog's suicide was questioned by some
including by your brother Hugh believing
that American intelligence agencies
might have murdered her to keep
Oppenheimer focused and to clip off a
possible communist influence and Nolan
references that Conspiracy Theory with
this brief shot just a second or too
long of a gloved hand holding Gene down
underwater drowning her though due to
this movie's subjective qualities and
editing style it could be hinted to just
be a fantasy in oppenheimer's mind
either way I love that Nolan tipped his
hat to this in 1945 Oppenheimer and
Groves pick a site that Abby calls
Trinity saying batter my heart
three-person God a reference to the poem
by John Dunn poetry that was reportedly
introduced to Oppenheimer by Gene
tatlock Groves and Oppenheimer meet
secretary War Henry Stinson who crosses
Kyoto off the list of targets because he
had his wife honeymoon there which is
apparently true he gives them to the
Potsdam Conference in July to have a
successful test and despite the rain
they successfully detonate the gadget
and Nolan shot a practical explosion he
says this is a real boom boom that they
detonated with very very little VFX now
initially we see it completely without
sound just so we can take in the visuals
of it you'll notice among this Pillar of
Fire you can see little Sparks multiple
techniques were experimented with by
Nolan's special effects team led by
Scott Fisher and Andrew Jackson ping
pong balls are smashed together paint
was hurled across walls luminous
magnesium Solutions were developed for
this the only sound we hear other than
oppenheimer's breath is the sound of him
and Jean having sex earlier in the movie
and him reading the Sanskrit and now I
am become death the destroyer of worlds
and then Nolan hits us with the boom
because the sound wave would be delayed
first it's extremely loud at opi's
observation camp and then it's still
pretty loud but just not as loud it
gross there area and then a softer
Rumble from where teller and fame men
are watching from so weeks after this on
August 8th Harry S Truman goes on the
radio to announce that the bombs are
dropped over Hiroshima Nagasaki and the
movie has been getting some criticism
for not showing these but this is a
point of view fixed movie it would be
horrible if this movie cut to the
Carnage I know Hiroshima Nagasaki it
would just be a complete artistic
betrayal to the story that this movie's
trying to tell and really would just
come up as so excessive now during
oppenheimer's victory speech The
Stomping on the bleachers triggers him
the walls behind him quake and he
becomes unable to hear any of the
cheering just like he was at first
unable to hear the bomb just really a
single blood curdling scream and then a
flash of light an Oppenheimer sees a
woman as her skin burns off her face
this is actually a cameo by Nolan's
daughter Flora Nolan he also included
Florida shot in interstellar as one of
the kids in the back of the truck during
the dust storm Nolan apparently loves
putting his kids in apocalyptic
scenarios to make these threats as
horrifying as possible to him
Oppenheimer still in a day's steps and
what he thinks is a burnt Corp and he
just seems haunted by the tearful
Elation of everyone in the room he sees
a couple hooking up under the bleachers
which we know will lead to a baby boom
which means even more victims of
possible nuclear war but also we see
Lily and Donald hornig the people who
are protesting the use of the bomb
towards the end of World War II after
Hitler shot himself they are now sobbing
at the use of a bomb then outside
Oppenheimer sees the guy puking his guts
out what kind of world has he brought so
Oppenheimer tells President Harry Truman
played by Gary Oldman that he feels he
has blood on his hands and Truman says
as he walks out don't let that cry baby
back in here reportedly Harry trubin did
call J Robert Oppenheimer a crybaby
scientist now in the Final Act of the
movie It's revealed that straws
orchestrated oppenheimer's security
clearance hearing as a denial to shut
him up really though just to suffer his
own Denial in his confirmation hearing
after David L Hill played by Rami Malek
a scientist Strauss chose to speak on
his behalf because he was part of the
Chicago group and not part of
oppenheimer's Los Alamos cult Hill turns
on Strauss instead so both Rivals are
rejected and the film ends back with a
fateful 1947 conversation between J
Robert Oppenheimer and Albert Einstein
by the pond at Princeton where Einstein
warns that just like him ABI will be
given awards that are not for him but
for the award givers and we see that
future sure in which president Lyndon
Johnson will present the Fermi award to
Opie in 1963 right after he takes office
teller returns to Sheikh Abby's hand but
Kitty refuses to shake his hand which
was based on a true story and something
that teller reportedly later cried over
in the final exchange of the movie we
learned that Albert and Opie's exchange
had nothing to do with straws but was
really simply these two scientists
circling back on their worries about
teller's math back in the early 40s
Oppenheimer says Albert when I came to
you with those calculations we thought
we might start a chain reaction that
might destroy the entire world and
Albert says I remember it well what of
it hanapi says I believe we did Ludwig
yornsson's Amazing Music storms in
Einstein frowns now filled with the same
existential dread and guilt that Abby
suffers from that every decision he made
as a scientist only brought the world
closer to Doom we hear the returning
bleachers stomping we see ICBM Rockets
exhaust Trails through the clouds Opie's
sitting back in Borden's B2 cockpit
watching nuclear war go down around him
nukes of rap doing on the surface of the
planet a wall of fire engulfing the
globe and then Opie shuts his eyes
closed just as he did his nightmares at
the beginning of the film and we cut to
Black on a discordant violin note as
Prometheus is chained to a rock and
tortured for eternity thank you so much
for watching this and let me know your
favorite part of this film subscribe to
all three of new Rockstar's channels
follow me on all social platforms at
eavos thanks for watching bye
foreign
[Music]